[Music]
so I'm on Episode six seven now in terms
of the episodes are recorded for my
podcast and just something that I've
sort of learned in the process which i
think is a really really cool part of
starting a podcast is you get to learn a
lot from others which I absolutely
absolutely love them it sort of just
encouraged me encouraged people
encouraged me sorry too to do it even
more and I've really really enjoyed it
so I that's a great thing about the
podcast as well because your number
you're putting yourself in a position
where you're you're asking questions can
be a bit selfish with them although
obviously you want to ask questions
which you feel like obviously the people
that listen will get the most out of it
but you can be a bit selfish and ask
questions that you want to find out
which you're going to help you and where
you want your career or your life or
whatever and I think that's that's such
a great part of doing the podcast
obviously people can be learning from it
as well but you're gonna learn from it
as well because you get to speak and
interview people if you are doing that
for your podcast and learn from them I
just think it's so amazing how we can be
at the top of our game top of our game
and I'm nowhere near that where I'm at
in my career but you can still learn
from someone someone can sort of just
give you a gem or whatever and just have
a completely different perspective on
something which you didn't really look
at it that way before so that's what I
wanted to share about starting a podcast
that a real huge upside to it is that
you get to learn from it a lot you get
to learn how to do it you get to learn
how to ask good questions or get better
asking questions and you get to learn
yourself which is a bit selfish but
hey-ho and I think that's another great
reason great reason why if you're
thinking about starting a podcast why
should so just wanted to share that on
[Music]